let's go to area code 678 who's calling
today from 678
hi david this is jp from marietta
georgia how are you jp how are things in
georgia i'm worried about you guys
um that's actually what i was calling
about i didn't have really a particular
question besides
uh just for your comment on the state of
things yeah
i'm in the suburbs outside of atlanta
and
you know we have got tons of cases you
know every day
in georgia yep and i work in a music
shop
and i'm back in the store i mean there's
no
any kind of math mandate or anything
even for the
employees um not for the customers for
anything
yeah it's uh it is just ridiculous i'm
restringing people's guitars
that they're you know bringing in and
there's no way really to sterilize them
because
they're instruments and you can't put
disinfectant on them right
but and i had a funny thing i even uh
restrung a guitar
signed by paul ryan the other day
fairly dramatic imagine having a guitar
and wanting paul ryan to sign it you
know that
that's crazy it had a romney ryan
sticker on it so i think it was part of
a promotional
like giveaway or raffle or something
like that so
it's i'm hearing that you're you're
feeling unsafe at work essentially like
you're totally unprotected people are
coming in they're handing instruments
back and
back and forth you're not wearing a mask
they're not wearing masks
right i mean well i i do wear a mask
every day oh you do okay
you know have got sense i absolutely
it's just not required
yeah um so i have more conservative
bosses and
we're even back to doing like our bread
and butter is
lessons in person lessons and we've been
doing private lessons
in the store for a while as well myself
included
wow and now was the was the store
at one point closed when things were
more shut down
uh yeah we shut down uh from january
to march or they're about and
you know once once georgia you know
opened back
up we we came back in um
you know full force but kept our lessons
online for a few months
yeah starting in june um you know
completely ignoring all the numbers
starting in june we just decided to
let people start coming back in for
in-person lessons and do the owners or
your boss or whoever i don't know what
the structure is do they even talk about
preventing the spread of the virus or is
it just like we're open for business
that's it
um we we have bought air purifiers
and uh we've got um you know stations
with um with hand sanitizer um and we've
got cute little signs that they
say stay two guitars apart but other
than that uh not really
wow well i mean that's something i don't
know and let me ask you this i have a
couple friends down in georgia but i've
not asked them about this
in general like when you go to the
grocery store when people are
out is there increasingly the atmosphere
that things are just
normal or are people overall exhibiting
any kind of caution
um it's really hard to say i mean
it's really split just like you know a
good bit of uh you know everybody is
with you know people saying i'm not
gonna be a sheep
yeah and you know masks are are you know
you know make you not a man and yeah you
know the other half of people
uh seem like they're taking it seriously
but and the the school system seem to be
having a problem with this as well
cobb county where i am um that they were
gonna come back in full force and then
people got mad and then they said
they're going to all virtual and now
people are mad at that
so i don't know what they're going to
end up doing well listen
i don't envy you that sounds very very
tough and the georgia numbers are not
looking good all we can
i mean listen at this point i don't even
know what we're hoping for we're hoping
for a treatment we're hoping for a
vaccine we're hoping for some common
sense and
the removal of trump but it's we're
going to have some tough months ahead of
us i think it's undeniable
yeah yeah and uh uh well i have the
opportunity i want to thank you very
much for your work especially your live
streams and everything i'm glad you're
having good success with those they're
a good informative way to keep up with
the the lies that
you know trump and maggie manny and
everybody are spreading
thank you i really appreciate that
thanks for calling in great to hear from
you
let's go next to our caller from the 402
area code
caller from 402 what's your name where
are you calling from
hi david uh it's william from omaha
nebraska
william from omaha the oracle of omaha
is how we're going to put you into our
into our system okay um
yeah my question was actually about um
about an election that's going on uh in
nebraska right now so
there's uh the democratic
primary winner for the u.s senate is
uh chris jassinek and he's recently uh
recently screenshots have come out of
him making
crude sexual jokes to his campaign staff
and uh the nebraska democrats have voted
to
replace him with uh alicia shelton but
since jassnick
already won the primary he has to step
down right
um there have been petitions to call him
to like end his campaign
and my question was uh do you think
there's any chance that he actually
steps down uh since he already won the
primary
because like i definitely don't want to
vote for his opponent ben fass
i have no idea now is is ben sass
cruising to re-election regardless
um it's uh it's kind of
you know i'm i'm not sure he's the
incumbent right now yeah he's
uh he's popular
in in my area it's kind of hard to judge
from omaha i mean let me put it this way
i've not read anything about that seat
being one of the ones democrats
could take is that fair to say it's not
like ripe for the picking
for a republican to lose
well yeah nebraska is also kind of a
toss-up state now we used to
lean republican but in the more recent
polls um
we're getting more and more blue
so um if there's in my opinion
if he doesn't step down i would think
that it would be
for sure that then sas would get
reelected yeah i'm not able
to find any polling i mean listen i
don't think there's any way to force
this guy to step down
i really don't know about the messages i
don't know about the race i really don't
know anything about it but
i'm not aware of any way to force him to
step down and
i guess the reason i was asking about
whether it would be close or not is
uh if if ben sasse is going to win
either way
maybe that figures into the calculation
but i really just don't know enough
about it to say
okay well uh thanks for your time david
i really appreciate it
thank you i appreciate the phone call